dans un monde où les écrans ont envahi
notre quotidien
une équipe de scientifiques et
transportés dans le futur du numérique
oh
mo
tichy scop
sa mission maîtriser la fusion entre
humains et machines
et m cette nouvelle puissance au service
de la recherche et de l'industrie
avec des univers en 3d des bras
robotisés
des murs entiers couvert de pixels et
toutes ces interfaces encore à inventer
[Musique]
dans cette course à la technologie les
humains auront ils le temps apprivoisé
ces écrans toujours plus performants
[Musique]
oubliez tout ce que vous pensiez
connaître des interactions entre humains
et machines
dijonscope voit déjà bien plus loin
[Applaudissements]